Russia and Syria have heavily criticized
the latest report by the organization
for the prohibition of chemical weapons
on April's alleged Doomer chemical
attack in Syria Alexander Shulgin
permanent representative of the Russian
Federation to the OPCW was among experts
presenting concerns at a news conference
in Hague in the Netherlands he spoke to
RT the report provided by the Technical
Secretariat more exactly the
fact-finding team is a full overrun gaps
discrepancies and inconsistencies and
these are just preliminary assessments
by the Russian experts our final
conclusions will be provided a little
bit later the initial report by the OPCW
was published on the 1st of March it's
concluded that a toxic chemical
containing reactive chlorine was used as
a weapon however Russian and Syrian
experts know the fact-finding missions
actions were not compliant with the
Chemical Weapons Convention they
highlighted concerns over the collection
of testimonies from witnesses both in
Syria and abroad the opcw's accused of
politicizing the reports and is
criticized for suggesting that Syria's
government is to blame experts also
found a lack of neutrality and
objectiveness as well as distortion of
facts alexander shulgin adds there are
appears to have been external pressure
on the organization while it was
preparing the report well I do think
that there was a kind of pressure and
the investigation lasted one year and
practically and it was a to say it
mildly not transparent
shirin's forints for instance were
entitled to receive their share of the
probes probes collected
all the all the all the this you know
the incident but it took maybe six or
seven months for the Technical
Secretariat to share with assurance
these probes my impression is that the
Technical Secretariat experts simply did
not dare to contradict the version put
forward by the Americans first who
didn't hesitate to designate the Syrian
authorities as main culprits and based
on this conclusion they carried out this
attack on April the 14th and
incidentally just a couple a few hours
before the arrival in Damascus of the
Technical Secretariat team
you